étrange balade à la réunion texte de
christelle minier photographie perdant
chez moka édition il ya d'abord eu ses
trois pingouins qui bronzer sur le sable
puis ce panda qui voulait jouer à cache
cache avec moi dans les cannes j'ai
trouvé ça bizarre
à travers les herbes de la savane une
crééra rue a surgi et m'a fait sursauter
j'ai couru vite pour me cacher au bord
de la rivière
deux gros yeux observer sans un bruit
j'ai filé dans la forêt on entend des
glisser allons sur les branches j'ai
traversé la plage sur le dos d'un zèbre
sauvage nous avons galoper galoper quand
une girafe massoud a demandé voulez vous
vous baignez
quelle étrange balade a dit l'éléphant
étonnez
vous avez dit étrange un rhinocéros à
roulettes m'a doublé sur la piste jean
perdait les pédales c'est alors que des
pas ont fait trembler la plaine
ingrat raisonnée et là je me suis
réveillé